les coureurs étaient au rendez vous le
départ de la course royal s'est faite à
10h à la pièce d'eau des suisses du
château de versailles pour deux parcours
10 et 20 km 722 participants se sont
élancés pour la 7e édition de la course
royal il ya des passages un peu de dans
la campagne
un petit passage un peu boisée là et
c'est ce que je recherche
ça s'est bien passé c'est une course qui
est plutôt dur c'est bapela il ya des
chemins des côtes c'est donc faut savoir
gérer
je suis assez boueux donc ça glisse être
un peu compliqué dans les champs les
participants se sont confrontés aux
conditions météorologiques la pluie
était au rendez vous pour cette septième
édition de la course royal comme on dit
dans le jargon des commandes etc ans
agressé le terrain et quelques petites
chutes mais sans aucun danger corps et
âmes bien contient terrain petit peu
gras parce qu'ils sont en train à semis
a trahi des enfants en situation de
handicap participent également à cette
course aborde trois jours elle est un
fauteuil tout terrain accompagnés des
coureurs des dunes de l'espoir et de
franchissant le mur
présent depuis trois ans ils ont
effectué le parcours des 10 km ça s'est
très bien passé
et puis à sur cinq ans page a eu invité
à étudier parce que c'est ma meilleure
amie ça fait dix ans que j'avais
parcouru effectivement c'était de son c
j'ai retrouvé des sensations que j'ai
connu il ya dix ans l'heure des
résultats a sonné la grande gagnante des
10 km s'appelle l'uci pour sa première
participation à la course
royal elle est arrivée en première place
avec un temps de 42 minutes et 47
secondes
une huitième édition de la course royal
est espérée avec encore plus de coureurs
l'année prochaine